una vez más las manifestaciones llenaron
las calles de las ciudades francesas en
contra de la Reforma pensional de Manuel
macron en León Gen Y por supuesto París
la coalición de ocho sindicatos convocó
protestas para rechazar la aprobación
definitiva del Consejo constitucional de
este proyecto de ley que sube la edad de
jubilación de los 62 a los 64 años y que
alrededor del 70% de los franceses
desaprueba
los sindicatos anunciaron que las
movilizaciones se mantendrán
no se puede gobernar un país contra su
pueblo Emmanuel macron no puede seguir
dirigiendo el país sino retira esta
reforma para permitir la calma y
reencontrar la vía del diálogo
la oposición política también se
pronunció tanto desde la izquierda como
desde la derecha
la decisión del Consejo constitucional
demuestra que está más atento a las
necesidades de la monarquía presidencial
que a las del pueblo soberano la lucha
continúa y debe reunir sus fuerzas si la
decisión del Consejo constitucional
cierra la secuencia institucional el
destino político de la Reforma de las
pensiones no está sentenciado el pueblo
aún tiene la última palabra le
corresponderá preparar una alternativa
que revierta esta reforma inútil e
injusta
sin embargo el gobierno defiende que no
hay más que hablar
el consejo constitucional ha juzgado la
reforma conforme a nuestra Constitución
tanto en el fondo como en el
procedimiento el texto ha llegado al
final de su proceso democrático esta
tarde no hay ganadores ni perdedores
la decisión de la corte elimina algunos
artículos de la propuesta de ley pero
avala su esencia Elevar la edad de
jubilación para evitar que el sistema de
pensiones sea deficitario y cierra la
puerta que se convoque un referendo para
consultar el texto con la población una
vía que la oposición quería abrir Se
espera que el gobierno de macron
promulgue la ley este mismo fin de
semana